oh there's no one here
what is this platform what is this
platform the youtubes
don't worry I'll entertain the nobodies
who are here on a Saturday afternoon
you take masses all right we should just
do one of those like sleeping live
streams oh yeah or a mukbang
let's do a mukbang just eat we're just
hanging out and literally just seen
who's super chasis while we sleep who
finds us sexy enough to sleep hey Ethan
hey Lando John Dida there's another John
here don't worry wide some fries here
he's just pulling up a chat on the
computer yo yo Paul Joe there's a lot of
people are people are chiming in
people are chiming in alright ready 1
yep we got this we got this literally I
figured it it's just the live streaming
menu itself you just have to believe
we've figured out how to do the live
stream all right guys let's do this
John I'm back in your chat I'm in the
chest tube right for you guys there we
go intimate there we go that's much
better
hey Anthony della Della's back in the
chat all right so it's Saturday don't
expect a lot of people of be here this
is a good enough number for us right now
um hey so here's how this Amy says hi
never never says hi to me freakin a NIC
- so every day no no no not this live
stream though because then it'll look
like I told no I'm gonna Grubman uh we
can't be under too long because I'm
actually gonna go catch the lighthouse
in about an hour so I need time to get
some gas and drive over to the theater
as well question/answer hey yes Ben C
yes
so you guys help control this movie news
livestream we are gonna go off of your
questions that's how this operates you
guys will fuel lead the conversation and
we just kind of pick and choose which
ones stand out to us the most all right
so here we go but before we go into that
I got to give you guys dope trope number
five so this is a little segment I came
up with basically these are tropes and
movies and no one really points out but
I definitely notice they occur a lot and
sometimes they get on my nerves and
sometimes it's just whatever what's up
epic voice guys in here so dope trouble
no five I discovered this when I was
watching Breaking Bad at night and I was
like I'm whatever is gonna do this
cliche it sure is El Camino the movie
and sure enough it did this cliche it's
not really a minor and the minor wrist
of spoilers alright doesn't really spoil
because this is something that happens
in all these movies and shows as well as
when a character is frantically
searching a room for something they've
torn the part they've been probably at
it for hours they montage through it and
then they give up and they just like sit
and they like you and usually here's
what it is if you seen El Camino it
happens in the movie and it's like
predictable because this isn't so many
movies and shows where they like hit
their head against like oh that sounds
kind of hollow what is this then they
open it up there it is it's right there
the whole time they give up and they
augers sit on it or hit their head
against the wall it's one of the two and
that's what they always do
so yeah John where's you I thought
you've successfully pulled up the chat
we using my phone I don't see any chat
on the computer there I don't see any
chat I know what they want us to I don't
know what they want us to talk about
okay what's the first bit of movie news
you'd like us to cover people have we
seen The Watchmen yeah we just did an
episode 1 review of it clearly you don't
have your notifications turned on there
buddy
you need your notifications turned on
what come on let's get some Nutter I
like there you
yeah we'll remember how to successful
the chat next time what I missed one
piece of [ __ ] monitor us John what
question do we have alright alright
let's get a question going on um whoo
what are we going as for Halloween for
house I have a hat of Dustin from
stranger things but I need to find a
couples costume in the next couple of
days to do with my girlfriend cuz that's
the best way to do life John do you have
a costume in mind uh yeah I'm gonna try
and do an Otis Firefly ritual variant
from the end of house of 1000 corpses
when he's in the red tunic and the skull
makeup cuz I got the hair now that's
true and and if I can get the right kind
of red tunic I might do a double and
cover my arm in tinfoil and be Edward
Elric and just tie my hair in a braid
from Full Metal Alchemist so two ideas
this year I agree there's gonna be a lot
of people who are gonna be going as
Joaquin Phoenix from the jogger that'll
be the every year at working haunts and
stuff our wrap party would we would just
it would just be called The Joker party
because inevitably half the party would
be addressed as Joker Harley that's good
oh uh 2020 movie we are looking forward
to most John and I actually just figure
this out like two days ago we were in
unison yeah we what we went through the
whole list of 2020 movies that our
patreon page we do weekly Q as someone
had a question about like most
anticipated 2020 films and we boiled
down to looking over all the months we
both decided on saw the Chris Rock City
rock saw with Sam Jackson Jackson Darren
Bausman coming back like that just
sounds sis unicorn nipples
oh thanks princess is there a question
you have I mean we appreciate the super
chat but do you have a question to
follow the super chat we always like to
all that sort the only way we can give
back if you do if you do a super chat
with us maybe Union is just wants to
hear us you know expels upon our
excitement for saw true Oh Chris classic
Chris Donahue thank you buddy that is a
classic super chat
right there but really quick we got to
finish up John we have to finish the
answers
I know arise even if people are so kind
to contribute we got to finish the
answers okay saw because it just sounds
so weird and different like a weird
combination mix saw could use some
reinvigoration it's a franchise where
you and I have both seen all the movies
we even did a saw parody sketch or a
spoof sketch called Greg saw no no if
you guys have seen it you guys should go
check it out so yeah sorry it's not
Black Widow were the Eternals or Wonder
Woman 1984 or edit it is sorry it also
seems like after eight movies maybe they
are to the point where they'll just
throw caution to the wind and really let
them go out there with it so this is
true yeah do we think the new Star Wars
movie is gonna be good Chris Donahue
John Doe for sure I think it'll be
really well made cuz they're always
really well made III think I'll be a
satisfied movie goer I mean I'm not the
type of Star Wars viewer who's gonna get
furious if they do a whole number of you
know subversive or out there things so I
might not be the best person to ask I'm
a little weary to see how they stick the
landing as a trilogy mm-hmm I don't know
I guess I don't know if I think it's
gonna be good I think it'll be well made
if that's that makes sense uh yeah I
think it'll I think it'll be good I hope
it will be now the question is will it
be great that's the thing I don't like a
good I think no matter what it's
probably gonna be good I'd be so
surprised if I was like that was a bad I
like the last jet if I'm one of the
people who likes blast and I am probably
gonna like this give them like every
Star Wars trailer looks incredible and
makes you really excited and that's what
they're supposed to do but I feel like
in this trailer they showed me some
things that in a traditional setting I
would be like a little much to show in
the trailer yeah I think but at the same
time they're hinting at things that I
didn't necessarily think they were gonna
do and I was kind of hoping they were
gonna do so that aren't the normal stuff
we've done before so hopefully fair
enough John shoes another question let's
do it oh I saw one
do you have nipple shows princess
unicorn ELLs asked always I got nipple
chill it's weird you know people
sometimes think I'm just making
iMeet jokes about it I was that's a real
thing that happens with I have like
emotional nipple children it's not
always excited nipple chills
sometimes approaches sometimes I'm just
like like scared and I get nipples I
feel it it rises in my shirt so yeah
it's a real thing I go through but but
did you find a real question I did and I
make you princess I'm gonna amend it
because I know what the answer is gonna
be
so excluding bumblebee favorite
transformers new transformers honestly I
kind of roll together first one is the
one I kind of like I didn't mind the
first Mark Wahlberg one I don't remember
the subtitle but I didn't mind it I
though that was fine where's Sally you
know that's like weird Thank You
princess you we're so that's that's the
whole thing you're aiming for right now
it's at least 15 minutes away you know
what I'm gonna bring her back on the
channel next month mm-hmm
I've haven't so surprised haven't really
seen her in the flaws since my birthday
or something like that in a while but
she'll be back I promise you she'll be
back I'll screenshot your question send
it to her don't I am one day I'll put it
on one of these live streams too you
could pressure to seeing how many MCU
movies she's seen and she's gonna be
like oh no your subscribers hate me
mMmmm I can't go to hell Sally but
that's why I love you anyway
ooh
oh there's oh wait what do you think
about Hawkeye being recast is he being
recast or just the end waitis cocci
being recast yeah that's what somebody
asked what do you think Rayanne what do
you think about Hawkeye being recast are
you talking about the fact that they're
gonna probably have Bishop being the
role of Hawkeye after like at the Disney
Plus show how it's gonna segue is that
it can we finally get jensen ackles in
the bow and arrow
I really mind if Hawkeye is reek I feel
bad for jeremy renner cuz it feels like
it'll never got in his do but I feel
like there's a Disney plush show he'll
be getting it here Renner is always
great at endgame he's always doing good
in franchises that he never gets to take
over on his own
that's true yeah hey someone asked one a
joke or two and Joaquin Phoenix you
gotta watch the latest movie fights that
I was on which was just the most recent
movie fights I pitched a whole joke or
two idea but generally no I would not
want a joke or two but if there was a
joke or two I have an idea that I think
you guys should go check out on that
movie fights channel hey Michael Beason
here Michael Burnett they're considering
firing Jeremy Renner because of some
drama with him was it because he closed
his app is it because you said that
sexual comment about Scarlett Johansson
from forever ago What did he say I don't
really remember it was a long time ago
he can't call her a [ __ ] or something
no damn that's mad I called Black Widow
was it called
Scarlett Johansson something like that I
forget what it was of someone some of
them I know in there so here's an
interesting one
okay what's the first movie you've seen
do you remember what it could have been
first movie I saw in the theaters was
Jurassic Park that was three years old
that scream my ass off and that
apparently my family thought I was gonna
go watch some movie about Wonder kisses
and we're back shouts out to the few
people who remember the animated movie
we're back what about you John Ann I'm
the first movie my my most vivid young
movie going experience was with blade
but I have to imagine it was before them
I feel like the first movie I would have
seen would have been like a Marx
Brothers movie or something like that I
wonder how many of these good you guys
could respond to what I'm about to say -
how many of these what people are asking
or what you see in almost every life
scream chat about movies do you think
I'm like I'm sure if I went to the camp
be a show livestream it would be like
all these okay thoughts on David Lynch
David Lynch here's my thought I always
really got it
in the labs director Marvel Hyde can
never just put on David Lynch you can't
just suggest David Lynch I gotta be at a
really prepared moment to code got to be
prepared to be confused
titillated a little disturbed unsettled
yeah
cuddled a little bit someone's asked me
100 Jon campy I gotta hit him up because
he actually called me it's like we're
like a few weeks ago he called me and I
was I had to leave town
and he's like hey can you come on
tomorrow tomorrow morning and I named
him yeah and I was like man it's been so
long I love to but I can't so I gotta
hit him up I feel like because whenever
I say no do any of these collabs whether
it be screen junkies or he can't be I'm
always under the impression that because
I denied this one time that they think I
never want to come on again it's like
it's always the fear of me saying you
know I have a hard time sometimes saying
no okay breaking news from Michael B
Renner apparently was violent with his
ex-wife and threatened suicide or murder
suicide don't quite remember the exact
deeds that's a grim thing damn that's
heavy that's person I'll tell you I'm
not knowledgeable enough to comment on
that I haven't researched it haven't
heard about it this is the little list
I'm hearing about so I preferred not to
comment on it at the time he was that
violent I hope he is atoned and some fun
stories about the guy being kind of rude
and off-putting before but never
anything like that I could kind of see
it if he has a violent temper inside his
Jeremy Renner have you not seen some of
the movies he was in do you know Hurt
Locker have you seen the movies where is
not I've read your name if there are
actors that play like Psychopaths or
have like terrible tempers that we love
them it's best to like I've never should
have been surprised if this suddenly
some story comes out and they're you
know they've done something horrible or
something like that
somebody said Funko movie and and I just
heard about that and that seems like a
really odd
it seems like a worse idea than the lego
movie no not to say the leg of movies
about actors just like a not as good
version of that the allegedly point
pointed a gun at her and threatened to
kill himself wow we got a read up on
this this is crazy this is a fun live
stream ton six great this is gonna be
advertiser friendly question you guys
what's your favorite celebrities
domestic violence story was it Sean Penn
and Madonna come on it listed below
what's your favorite Jesus we're gonna
get off that topic is that's something I
want to read up on the arrowverse hell
yeah I haven't seen any of the latest
season of arrow but there's only been
two episodes that are buried so far but
I need to go check it out and yeah I'm
super super excited for for crisis on
Infinite Earths absolutely that is that
is a funny one I mean the funniest ones
Christian Bale but that's not domestic
violence that's onset violence some very
different once a little bit more
humorous for some reason John say this
person's then Alexander Supertramp their
got it Lynnae Lynnae hey you're already
a patron dude we just you know we just
uploaded the Bray Wyatt video and your
boy Seth Rollins apparently burned down
the fire flight fun house yeah hey about
that mate my girlfriend told me all
about that
thank you Anna you're so sweet maybe you
should keep but make sure to save some
money get yourself a nice Halloween
costume I know you work at a school kids
are gonna want to see their well you
know someone they were with the adults
and it's always fun the adults are
worried cause it's not just like a witch
you know or you know like a hat or a
shirt yeah this is my Halloween costumes
be like a [ __ ] Green Lantern that's
right that's what the kids need have you
guys seen the new Terminator movie yet
no no no have not no it's it's I'm so
stressed out about the day
after Halloween because I don't I
honestly I don't want to go watch
terminator on a lawn Thursday night on
Halloween night I don't want to do that
and so I'm not going to as much as I'm
looking forward to the movie Halloween
is also a David yeah
so but then I'm like but the Irishman
comes out on November 1st that's it I
have very limited release it sound like
to shoot should we just go in the 6 hour
movie day once you factor in some
trailers and stuff good commute it's the
last thing I want to do is watch both of
those movies on the same therapy yeah
our minds I'm looking forward to it and
yes someone asked we are look the
Irishman is gonna be on ok look I'm a
Scorsese not all right I love his movies
so much and I was telling my girlfriend
just theater Dara of how when I was
young like a little kid
I would watch us course a De Niro film a
Pacino film I didn't hear from a Pacino
film all to accumulate to the movie heat
it was my own little cinematic universe
so the idea and I've always wanted
Pacino to work with Scorsese so the idea
that we're finally getting this movie
I'm gonna watch it in the theaters no
matter what I'm not gonna do a Netflix
reaction I'm not gonna watch it watch
the person that looks I'm gonna go watch
this in the theaters no matter what if
anything if Terminator was available
that looks like a watch instead so yeah
that's yes someone's asking we are
planning on already booked an editor
where we edit all the shows repeat all
the show extra patreon YouTube but we
booked an editor already you know our
guy has a nerd chronic for the
mandalorian we will be covering that for
sure
streaming laws about patreon reaction
highlights will be up on YouTube and
yeah
the Irishman is three and a half hours
yeah John yeah do we have somebody asked
what our favorite movies of the year are
support that's the one you want we're
never mind let's go with the end game
Joker
do you watch hey John what's your
favorite foreign movie that's a great
question
probably right now it's accent but you
know at the moment or maybe sing Street
but I feel like that's kind of cheating
because it's you know it's like Irish
its foreign but it's not really a
stretch you know all right I got a deep
cut here it's called fearless hyena it
was a Jackie Chan film in his younger
years that is a film that I think it's
hysterical some beautiful traditional
kung fu choreography with the Jackie
Chan mix on it I think it's all that's
like the number one foreign film I grew
up on so just nostalgia I think there's
like better movies than that you know
like Pan's Labyrinth is probably the
best one but you know but I would have
to say my personal favorite is a
fearless hyena mmm-hmm reduce pawn John
your thoughts on that
I am nervously optimistic I mean like
I'm excited for the fact that they're
doing it I feel like it's gonna be a
tall order until it gets done absolutely
properly but um it seems like they're
going about it the right spiritual way I
don't know how trustworthy Todd
McFarlane is as a filmmaker but I am
excited to see what happens it's funny
this videos titled movie news catch up
we are not catching up on the only
here's the movie news we got you here
about Jeremy Renner I was like I really
been on like my movie news sites as much
this week I was hoping to get some movie
news conversate I'm doing it wrong I'm
having fun with these questions by Adam
driver as this Scarecrow who just said
that scene it is that real that's a real
2021 is that TV that can't be real
because that would be up her have to be
perfect casting her Paul Dano is the
skater going to work
either one of those too but I think with
Adam driver's height his voice his body
yeah he like lost some weight - yeah
like kind of slim tortured soul Adam
driver and as Scarecrow would be pretty
sweet casting or called Anna or Paul
Daniel ops drops out Adam driver
replaces the Riddler oh oh c'mon come on
Master Joe Johnny Johnny thank you so
much hope you guys are having a good day
do you guys watch peaky blinders if not
you should definitely check it out I
have seen a handful of episodes peaky
blinders actually and I enjoyed what I
saw
I loved Cillian Murphy man he's got a
place in my heart for all eternity
I've seen a lot of people a lot of
social media accounts that I follow put
up I haven't seen me episodes actually
but I've seen a lot of scenes that
people just upload on their social media
I follow means every time I watch the
scene from that I go I can't watch this
show yeah hence is Tom Hardy on it for a
little bit - he might be it's like a
reoccurring character I think someone's
gonna correct me and yell at me in the
comments yeah hmm Roseanne Barr as
poison ivy if she wants to get her
career back that would be great
I would prefer that Oh double-oh-seven
no time to die any thoughts yeah they
just rat filming
cary fukunaga that means cary fukunaga a
completed film and that yeah of all the
films and things he's been attached to
lately there he is
laughter been taken off no I'm like oh
damn you got one done oh I just heard
the news today about that and I was like
oh this is actually do as much as I've
been saying like be roles and offset
photos I'm like I still the next
Fukunaga Joyce will not feel real until
it's here I like I won't believe the
flash movies getting made
until there's a trailer lobby
you don't have to do a rap filming
photoset thing i like what when there's
a trailer then I'll believe it I believe
it it's a number two but like this
double-oh-seven oswego damn it is
complete oh yeah breaking casting news
apparently cardi B is gonna be in Fast
and the Furious 9 yeah is announced a
few days ago perfect
I hope not it's just I think cardi B
would be perfect for it is perfect for
cardi B's like I um I would say this
Olivia
listens to cardi B a lot which freaks me
out because he's always talking [ __ ] on
her boyfriends or ex-boyfriends and I'm
like that's what she thinks but I love
cardi B in interviews I think she is
hysterical and also she's got the
attitude for it and she's got the energy
as well I'm mortix I'd be more excited
about her being cast in it then I feel
like if even if cardi B got brought into
the same role I feel like it would be
altogether shinier well I hope she has
like an actual scene actual role because
well the whole this movie takes place in
a strip club news there you go yeah I
mean she's like she has a little bit of
time in hustlers barely any strain time
well it wasn't like the supporting just
another character yeah but she's like
barely in it and only in the first half
sort of you know so it would be cool she
had like an actual you didn't feel old
it effects even if it something like a
big part but uh but like even if it's
like ten minutes still like something
worthwhile that makes it that leaves an
impression you know what I mean Jean
DITA thanks John Deana thoughts on
darkish Barney movie by get out star
which get out stars John let's do this
do all that scoob's Google this
oh is this you know you know YouTube
videos I love or are the ones when they
do like those compilations of when like
youtubers who didn't realize they were
recorded we got to do a fake one it's
like go live and not react like we did
in real they were not aware that we went
like that be fun okay Barney the
Dinosaur moving because I got nothing
and who's to get out star in it
Daniel Kalu yes but it is Daniel Kaluga
oh with his production comfortable okay
fascinating do you guys know about this
do you guys know about this movie okay
team will adapt Barney and Friends the
iconic kid shows her wow that is a weird
competition ever pretty difficult yet
for the guy to do this what would the
Barney movie be about the lower the
mythology it's gonna be a dart character
study we're gonna learn how Barney came
to have his own show and live in that
house and you know he's surrounded by
all those other creatures he had an
abusive mom and it knows that he wants
to just host his own show all those the
opposite of all those things for every
child this Barney movies inspired by
films like you go call yeah yeah what
the hell that sounds so strange
mm-hmm what would Mark Ruffalo be like a
Spider Man Mark were hired you'd be very
Tobey Tobey Maguire would be a really
cool old man spider-man Peter yeah yeah
yeah what about a Bray Wyatt the fiend
movie just a couple of questions since I
gotta get going to go watch the
lighthouse
I'm sudden lights out hey going to go
turn on my TV to watch it it's on it's
been out for a few years
see let's see ooh what's your is this is
this good one what's your favorite scary
movie that's too easy watch this growl
right we'll find scream scream too easy
way too easy favorite revenge movie Kill
Bill Vol 1 I would say Kill Bill Vol
one's my favorite revenge movie for sure
yeah John do you have a favorite revenge
movie a revenge movie
well kind of Devil's Rejects is is like
a dueling revenge movie so I think I'll
go there alright yeah
I'll let you have it thanks ma'am I want
you to have a fat and ass off on a
strong one but people seem to really be
loving the light house yeah you know
your Drive shirts Thanks I'm gonna get a
third one one day okay
favorite guilty pleasure movie there's
that one Oh easy easy favorite guilty
pleasure do you have one I got a name
some well I guess so one of my go to
this this is guilty pleasures you don't
mess with the Zohan think that movies uh
really funny it's probably incredibly
problematic but it's it's cartoonish in
a way and committed in a way that I
don't often get from Adam Sandler that I
just really hit the sweet spot for me
that's the one
what about you wha-wha West oh yeah
easily I don't know it's a guilty
pleasure
that's just a place you look it's a
misunderstood comedy I'd say Twilight
but III do enjoy watching all those
movies I see the theme with Wild West
when I watch that I honestly I feel dumb
because I'm they're going I don't know
why this is like considered one of the
worst things ever
I didn't even Will Smith like rejects
this movie so right that's how I always
feel when I watch it like there's
something wrong with me that I genuinely
think this is an alright job but
Twilight is is the whole franchise that
I watch and I go this is I I don't know
if I would call well in a way I would
call I have a love for Human Centipede
in movies okay so that for that
franchise I guess I would call a guilty
pleasure
yeah night owl thank you so much 9l
wants us to react to the fiend more from
my Bray Wyatt
well it was hard to get that unblocked
so actual feet mentioned pretty
incredible baby perhaps thank you yeah
we do have some merch
we just never really rocket or promote
it or anything we're not really good at
that we promote like patreon and
Stardust in a new year that'll be easily
identifiable at least a couple of things
murky yeah we do
I think it's pretty shirt spread right
now spread sure comm slash the real
rejects you can find any number of
different t-shirt designs and stuff like
that we may upgrade sometime well either
way guys thank you so much for being
here um you guys were rocker here's the
last question for ya who would you want
to play in a biopic who would I want to
play in a biopic mm-hmm the Indian guy
from inception and drag me to help do
you you or Shia LaBeouf you got it or
Adrian Grenier or Adam Brody I hope you
guys see a pattern here
oh this kind of my real answer would
have to be Anthony Kiedis Oh that'd be
mine I'm at my dream one and I would be
like no we're not lip-synching I'm the
real thing screw his voice
I would want to leave Jared Leto a
biopic about his downfall after playing
the Joker and turning into it yes man or
I'd want to be too hard Butler Oh Your
Honor I am a law-abiding citizen I don't
want to study the law anymore
you guys have a great time hopefully we
have time to cover the lighthouse on
Monday if not there's such a that's a
short gap for when a review is relevant
I know
go up like a lesson today two days after
it comes out it's not relevant anymore
people moved on the live stream review
is Robert Pattinson said anything about
the Batman again yet